W hand okay yeah I this little oh my god
oh yeah I should maybe get a couple of
band actually I'm Don rackliffe I'm
Lindsay Mendes I'm Jonathan gra and we
are here with BuzzFeed to do the puppy
interview and answer your
[Music]
questions I am not really a dog person
oh oh great time to mention that I have
done the puppy interview once before
it's just better than most interviews
cuz most interviews don't have puppies
did they pee on you that's my question
no I don't think so I don't remember
that if they did it didn't make enough
an impression to ruin the day okay yeah
[Music]
need thisy guy
hi oh hi
Budd
[Music]
hello
things started off before we'd actually
met on a the text chain and Jonathan and
Lindsay with Jonathan particular
Jonathan sends video messages and they
both sent video messages back to each
other and then I was like oh God are we
doing video messages I think they both
sent like spontaneous popping off this
quick video as I'm on my bike or doing
something and I I would be like I have
to make notes on everything they've said
I think I filmed the beginning of mine
probably like two or three times so I
was like ah I've said something stupid I
didn't mean that oh my God pressure now
I'm into the videos but at the start I
was like oh God is this going to be how
our relationship is formed and it kind
of was it was but it was yeah you we
send we send messages all the time this
one is so
[Music]
soft I think he would be Mary I knew you
were going
to because I'm a homosexual and so I did
a show with of with Olympia Dukakis rip
she is very big in the gay community for
many reasons Moon struck Steel
Magnolia and we did this play at the
public theater and she would come off
stage after her monologue and she'd be
like lot of gays out there cuz she would
know cuz the gays loved her and the gays
love Lindsay Mendes obviously as to
everyone and the streets and everybody I
would like to be Charlie cuz I like your
songs and I like your outfit the
other I would maybe be Joe reg's
character but also like I've seen do it
now so I I but I am ready to go on for
reg I'm working on my re impression
every night you do I really do You' be
great as regge as do yeah play as
dog I call you your real life names on
that's actually that's one of my
favorite things ever happened in the
show I've been being like hard on myself
or something about something and then
and when we had a really good old
friends and you were like very excited
for how well it gone for me and you hug
me at the end of the song and screamed
dly in front of a theater full of people
and then yeah I think all mics went down
but I was like just call me my real name
like that's not my name right now pretty
great it's actually funny we're like the
fre Bears drag her Dan's ready at like
quar 7 Dan's ready at quarter pass 7 in
full costume yes I'm yes which is also
unnecessary the wingsing in the wings
before the stage manager even at their
desk yeah Dan's already down there you
never know we might start 25 minutes
early one night I'm giving you that
sensible you know be ready at at places
getting my my wig on and John's wig
doesn't go on I like to feel like I've
just found myself on
stage and so he often
does oh God there's a fight there's a
fight okay you guys he is feisty he's
feisty oh my gosh the best ever we did
Wicked together she was my Glinda and
we've been really close friends ever
since and we've had kids at the same
time and had a lot of life since then so
it's so incredible to get to be with her
I I suggested her for the part and we
have our kids at the theater all the
time and it's just it's so wonderful
it's really
fun
baby's relationship to sleep and the
idea that if you like if I don't sleep a
lot then I will sleep more the next time
I try but if babies don't sleep a lot
then they still just don't sleep a lot
so you like there's uh that makes no
sense and I'm wondering like at what
point does that switch over to like our
version of sleep where if you're tired
you just sleep that's been like a
surprising thing to learn but I mean
everything like every day is you know
surprising and I can't talk about the
genuinely like profoundly surprising
things cuz I'll
cry we want to see it
cry interview let's not what this is for
cry over cry
[Music]
with Leah Michelle and I are in a
constant state of
rehearsal that's just that's just the
facts and this is kind of like you guys
this is basically
us this is basically us my dad had a
goat named leam Michelle um she was the
it was the goat that was always like at
the head of the pack sir sir sir I need
you to cool it I've just Cal this one I
need you to cool it wait is this a girl
or I might be a dog whisper you guys
it's a girl I'm sorry
ma'am when we were off Broadway and Dan
finished singing um Franklin Shephard
Inc this man aggressively was like bravo
bravo like screaming Bravo really loud
we were like who's that guy that's like
screaming um for Dan such a Dan fan and
it was Mandy
Patinkin just like the compliment of all
compliments because Manny Patinkin is a
sonheim god Legend and he was shooketh
by Daniel redcliffe I was it was that
was very cool to find out that was cool
Patty was there Off Broadway brette
Peters was there and a win tour was in
our previews Off
Broadway it's all Lady parts for
me I I want to be Maria in The Sound of
Music and I want to be what go
ahead that's my answer Maria and The
Sound of Music Dan I don't know I mean
like yeah I'm really not sure I would
love to do other s sometimes stuff but I
don't think I like I don't think I could
sing Bobby and Company eight times a
week you should do Bobby and Company at
some point need to do that but yeah I
don't know I that would be like I I
can't think of anything else that I
would like I'll know when I say it but
like I off the top of my head I can't
what do you want to do I I'm in
retirement you're in right now yeah
after this I don't know I think someday
I would like to be Mama Rose and
yes w w hey hey hey hey hey W guys dude
we were so cool before guys come here
come on
all us all the
puppies is your hand okay yeah I this
little bed oh I should get a couple of
bandid actually my God D just you're
fully just
bleeding you need a tourniquet did you
bite down I think it was this one did
you make oh yeah cuz your teeth are sh
do you think it was the one I'm holding
right now I don't know it was either
that one don't to blame a specific dog
tell us D we've got the we've got the
foot roll the
[Music]
tapes one fan who has made like action
figures of basically every part that I
played so like I have a model of myself
as Weird Al which is really really cool
yeah that is cool I've seen your your
Charlie one I've gotten a star named
after me before you got a what a star in
the sky that's pretty cool with a
certificate what about you John get a
star he must have had some cool stuff
given to you mate for you I'm clearly
the single one of the three of us cuz
the puppies
know I need love I had a man give me an
actual autograph of the real King George
what yeah wow yeah and I hung it in my
apartment that's really
cool what like hick is that an Aron hick
yeah like G oh I would say
cruelty
that's I would say like casual cruelty
meaning like I'm thinking of like people
that's that are like okay like people
think it's funny people think it's funny
or just like like uh
oh you're the one that made Dan bleed
you're the one Lind when people cut
their nails on the train oh
yeah Tink why do it at home why are you
doing on the train yeah good or why are
you doing it on the bus on the national
tour what go
on obviously puppy
wrangling nothing that's why I'm I know
exactly I have no other skills yeah
exactly have nothing I couldn't organize
anything uh I couldn't yeah I I really
it's this it's it's this all destitution
for me my mom is a teacher a gym teacher
and I always thought if I wasn't that
after I would be a teacher and I went my
brother started a school in Pennsylvania
with his wife and I went in to talk to
the kids uh to teach them acting and I
got so nervous they're like five or 6
years old I was more nervous for that
than any performance of mar W and did
they like you they likeed me okay it
wasn't it wasn't a 10 out of 10 you're
like oh oh right you made that that's
cool I was like smile
and then you're sad we were doing
later yeah so probably just stick with
that
ow don't fella it was you thank you this
has been us doing the puppy interview um
these wonderful sweet creatures are all
available to adopt from the NorthShore
Animal League America um and you should
do that they're great yes also come see
us in a show that we're doing called
merily We Roll Along at the Hudson
theater through a while I don't know
dates yeah I'm doing it until someone
tells me to
[Music]
stop